I like listen to like NPR, BBC in your pants, like all one story.
Like why did they even have different, like publications,
if they want to have a one narrative, they should just make it one channel.
Like North Korea so much easier for people to follow.
And I think it just,
it just reminds me of like the animal farm,
how it all began and the beginning just like, don't think, Oh,
it's not a big deal. It doesn't affect my life right now.
And then suddenly like, you start keeping big being purged and being executed.
And we are not in this state where like, we are executed, but like,
you literally get cancer and you don't like news platform, social media,
like you lose your voice.
And that is almost like similar execution for like activists like me.
Like if I lose my people, like my influence,
then I cannot let them know the truth. Right. How do I ever find the system?
[Inaudible].
Where like,
just where we're at in America and forgetting the election just generally, like,
you know, you mentioned some,
some of the negative things that have happened to you,
but obviously something truly incredible things have happened to you at the same
time.
So yeah,
I've been also starting my YouTube channel and like I was doing live and talk
about how pure socialism can, can be so poisonous can never work. And of course,
I'm sure, you know, like YouTube [inaudible] videos. Right.
And I was wondering like, how,
like any ideas should be offered debate. I thought that's what,
what freedom meant.
And here we have this like of like where we have to. I mean,
I went to Columbia in New York.
You can how it felt like for me going through another four years of oppression
there, like, they talk about pressure by men,
but there's another oppression that they cannot see.
And I think that's why I just don't know like how, even to fire,
I feel like I came to America like four or five years ago. And like, well,
you guys always like, it's crazy. Like how this.
No, we weren't. I promise you, we weren't always this crazy,
but we need people like you to, to help us find the way again. I mean,
that's why I wanted to have you on the show because you've,
you've lived through this stuff. You've lived through it.
And then when I saw the video and you're,
and you're somehow referencing my book and I'm going, this, this is crazy.
I mean, you you've lived through it.
I'm talking about this stuff at the idea level.
Although I fear that most of the things that I was worried about in the book are
starting to become true.
Yeah. It's uh, I mean on TV,
I didn't get robbed and seeing people how they're like, you know,
this is something you did read, like on the like conspiracy theory,
like new sites. These people were standing on the Michigan Avenue in Chicago,
like two, 2:00 PM. Like during the day near the Macy and whiskers are nearby.
And this people are seeing me being punched and calling me racist because they
only see what I think they could see. It was a color in their eyes.
The other group, I was like Asian, that's all.
And that's when I thought like, Oh, this is like, not,
it's not like I'm trying to on people. This is a complete gong madness.
And I don't even know how to go back to the,
like the meter zone where some sanity like whores.
Yeah. You, you sort of referenced this a little while ago,
but the idea that if you talk about these things, freedom,
free speech, all of the things that you've just described here.
But if you talk about them,
you're suddenly thought of as like right wing that this is now a right
wing thing.
How has that affected your ability to do your advocacy and
build bridges and things like that?
That's the thing it's so, so hard.
Like how they are just so easy to call him names now. Right? It's,
they're so busy,
like making few new names for people and then putting them into this little box.
And it's been very challenged, like actually doing these,
like all my friends were like, you are fighting for notice, can people,
you can not doing this. You can not talk about any of this problems.
Just stick with North Korea.
But like in order to North Korea and we serve those,
I need to like solve a China. First, the problem of North Korea,
the root is Chinese regime. Like Colin's party is not Kim Jong-un Kim.
John can never sell by me one day. He does this in pain.
So I'm how do I like fight with massive fight without like letting people know
what's happening and what China is doing to the humanity.
And then as soon as I,
of course criticize mainstream media for not like highlighting this issue,
then you know, I'm becoming a white, extreme, like quiz person.
What do you think about our media here? So as someone that grew up with,
as you said, one channel our media,
our mainstream media kind of feels like one channel at a certain level.
I mean, it is the one channel it's, uh, I, I just,
I can't, I mean, I like listen to like NPR, BBC in your pants,
like all one story. Like, why do they even have different, like publications?
If they want to have a one narrative, they should just make it one channel.
Like North Korea so much easier for people to follow.
And I think it just,
it just reminds me of like the animal farm,
how it all began and the being just like, don't thinking, Oh,
it's not a big deal. It doesn't affect my life right now.
And then suddenly like, you start keeping big being perched and being executed.
And we are not in this state where like, we are executed, but like,
you literally get cancer and you don't like news platform, social media,
like you lose your voice.
And that is almost like similar execution for like activist, like me.
Like if I lose my people, like my influence,
then I can not let them know the truth. Right. How do I ever find the system?
And like, my like fight is depending on the tech companies,
they are decision on me like one day, like, Oh,
I can let her be heard and I can be heard. But if they decide,
I cannot be heard, I cannot be heard. It's not up to me anymore. That's like,
what? Just fixing my within, like, how am I despite.
Yeah. You know,
it's interesting when people ask me what I love most about doing the show,
it's this right now, because think about like,
our lives are so different came from such different places.
And the things that you care about are the exact things that I care about. Like,
it's actually incredible how these sort of eternal ideas just end up bringing us
together.
Yeah, it does. I mean, I think it's, it's freedom is something that we can,
I think that's what I'm so like, scared for going to Columbia is like,
they don't understand like, like people when you're born with like two arms,
you never know what it feels like living without two arms.
And these people like at Columbia keep like wondering about what would it be
like without like freedom.
Like they have no clue what it's going to be without it. And they're keeping,
trying to experiment with this new idea. And there's like, no,
I know what it feels like living without this like rights and freedom and why I
trying to keep abandon them. They,
our ancestors fall from freedom of speech and like,
they bloody blow the four freedoms now for there was a price they paid for.
And now, because they got it for free,
this is a one to see what it feels like without two arms.
And it's not that great, like it's, your life is going to be so miserable.
And I think that's like,
what chucks me and horrifies me how ignorant and
this evil, this like ignorant Ida is. Can you also talk about.
A little bit about how it's not just like the,
the bad actors that spread these ideas,
but how the average person just kind of gives up,
like what you saw in North Korea when you were a kid and then China,
when you were a little bit older about how the average person just sort of
checks out. Cause that seems to be the stage that we're in right now here.
So yeah, I was thinking like, so in North Korea, if you commit a crime,
it doesn't end with you. Like it tracks two, three generations of your family,
sometimes eight generation, which means like you, your in-laws have cousins,
cousins like that. So one like the factory skateboards. Hi, hi lover.
He's like to read, I mean, 30,000 people got pushed for that.
And like, usually it's three generations. So your grandpa, your children,
all of it. And like any in America. Now, if there's like,
if I say something that was maybe completely aware, 30 years ago,
it gets back to me and I don't know,
what's going to get back to me three years down the road and how it's going to
affect my son.
Like people are talking about something that happened in the like timed
ancestral age, and they have to be responsible for that.
But this slavery thing that is like, exactly reminds me of that. Like,
because some, my accessory data so many, many lifetime ago,
how does it affect me? How does it make me figure it? Right?
And this is a complete idea from North Korea.
I don't know where these ideas are coming from.
Like we're making people so guilty and shame them.
And that's what North Korea is all about.
Shaming people and make them security and punish them.
Looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about international issues
instead of nonstop yelling out our international playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.